a rousing rendition of Oh Canada ruined
by foul play brothers and sisters all
lives matter to the gray remigio Pereira
alters the lyrics to our national anthem
and it's causing major international
controversy help you look close you can
see fellow tenor Fraser Walters caught
off guard by the improvisational act he
and many others are angered by Romeo's
revised lyrics we're all brothers and
sisters all lives matter to the greats
is definitely not in the original
composition and many Canadians are
deeming this disrespectful to our home
and native land but the deeper issue
lies specifically with the phrase all
lives matter which can also be read on
the carb remigio is flaunting to the
crowd the hashtag is courted controversy
because many feel that it undermines the
purpose of the black lives matter
movement black lives matter has received
more attention now than ever before in
the wake of last week's back-to-back
police shootings of Alton Stirling and
Phil and ro Castile
of course the principle is that all
lives matter but if we are going to be
honest with ourselves and take a look at
what's happening in our society and
black people are being killed by police
but then we have to be honest all eyes
don't axe
better and that's why we have this
rallying cry of black lives matter to
have some focus on what's happening in
our community in response to the musical
mishap the tenors have openly distanced
themselves from remigio in a statement
they call him extremely selfish and a
lone wolf the other members of the group
are shocked and embarrassed by the
actions of remedial Pereira who changed
the lyrics of our treasured anthem and
used this coveted platform to serve his
own political views he will not be
performing with the tenors until further
notice with his career on the line
remigio has taken to social media to
explain his actions I've been so moved
lately by the tragic loss of life and I
hoped for a positive statement that
would bring us all together one love
that was my singular motivation when I
said all lives matter because black
lives do matter they most definitely do
everybody's life matters I love you all
I don't think that his intentions or
what he really meant really means
anything the impact of his statement is
further legitimizing of the idea of all
life matter which is an offensive idea
and even Jennifer Lopez has found
herself caught in the all lives matter
debate she recently tweeted out this
photo using the controversial hashtag
the post got tons of backlash from her
followers and she has since deleted the
tweet while today other stars continue
to advocate for the black community
riding in your girl
Prinze car with a child in the back in
this video artists like Beyonce Lenny
Kravitz Alicia Keys and more all list
the 23 ways you could be killed if
you're black in America or attending a
birthday party
doing absolutely nothing not servile
enough
you